j'ai toujours dit que c'était une
candidature indépendante en tout cas
c'est une réelle satisfaction parce
qu'effectivement il ya un grand
différentiel
on est la deuxième liste après celle de
madame hidalgo et la liste socialiste à
paris donc c'est une grande satisfaction
de voir que nous avons pu rassembler
toutes les tendances de l'opposition
municipale pour se porter sur cette
liste et pour reconstruire une force
politique à paris est-ce qu'il va pas
falloir régler les comptes quand même de
la droite parisienne pour qu'une liste
dissidente fassent plus que la liste
officielle
je sais pas où est la liste officielle
parce qu'il ya une autre liste de droite
madame dumas qui a été élu et donc si on
fait le total de nos deux listes on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya eu une forte
contestation à paris vis-à-vis de la
direction nationale du parti
les républicains est effectivement un
fort désaveu la droite pouvait quand
même espérer progresser en terme de
nombre de sièges et finalement c'est
quatre sièges pour la droite il y avait
trois sièges +1 eu des i am a été
handicapé effectivement par la formation
politique qui s'est trompé dans le froid
et dans la composition n'aurait pu
trouver une liste beaucoup plus
harmonieuse je l'avais proposé à ma
formation politique en temps et en heure
ils n'ont pas voulu ils ont voulu faire
d'autre calculez bien les calculs
malheureusement ont mal tourné
finalement vous retrouvez votre siège de
sénateur vous retrouvez y compris avec
votre co listière donc deux sièges de
sénateurs
vous allez continuez votre travail au
sein des républicains on va continuer
notre travail au sein d'une force de
droite et du centre effectivement qui
doit se recomposer en tout cas on ne
peut pas continuer avec les mêmes et
avec ceux qui nous ont mené à l'échec il
qu'ils se trompent